The people turning out in vast numbers,
every one of your talks in Australia
been oversubscribed massively.
It tells you that they kind of get those
mortar,
this being told,
well,
it's one of the things that's so
interesting about dealing with
archetipal themes,
you know,
archetypal themes or archetipal because
they actually speak of the structure of
human experience.
That's why they last,
and so it's human nature and human
experience has a pattern.
You don't have the capacity to
articulate that pattern as an individual
in part because your life is too short.
You just can't figure it out.
But the,
the ancient representations of those
patterns are everywhere around you.
And you know,
some of them at the image you caught
onto them automatically,
you,
you fall into them.
If you go to a movie,
for example,
because movies always express archetipal
themes.
If you hear them articulate it,
you think,
I,
I knew that.
I just don't know how to say it.
That's,
that's the platonic idea of,
of,
um,
of learning as remembering your soul
already knows,
but it doesn't have the words.
And so when people talk to me about
watching my lectures,
let's say they say they basically say
one of two things,
if,
if it's.
If it's not just a simple thank you.
They say one of two things.
A third of them say,
quarter of them say,
when I listened to you talk,
it's as if you're telling me things that
I already know.
It's like,
yeah,
well that's exactly right,
because that's what archetypal stories
are there.
The description of what you already
know,
but that can be articulated.
And then who you are and how you see
yourself and the way you described
yourself all become the same thing.
So that's wonderful.
Then you're not at odds with yourself,
you know,
and then you have.
Then you're a functioning unity and that
makes you much stronger and more
indomitable than you would otherwise be.
And then the other thing that people
say,
and this is more like three quarters of
them,
is that they say,
I was in a very dark place.
I was addicted.
I was,
I was drinking too much.
I had a fragment,
did relationship with my fiance and I
wasn't getting married.
Things weren't going very well with my
family.
My relationship with my father was
damaged.
I didn't have any ame.
I was wasting my time.
Some variant of that,
some combination of those and they say,
well,
I've been watching your lectures.
I've decided to establish a purpose.
I'm trying to tell the truth and things
are way better and I've.
And so let's say I've done maybe eight
or nine large scale public talks in the
last two months,
so that's probably 20,000
people and about half of them,
a third to half of them estate
afterwards to talk to me,
so that's about 7,000
people who have said that to me and then
people stop me on the street all the
time and tell me exactly that story,
which is just wonderful.
You can't imagine how good it is to be
able to go to places you've never been
and to have people stop people in the
streets spontaneously and say,
look,
my life is way better than it was.
It's like it's so good and so,
and I've got like,
I don't know,
35,000
letters from people since last August.
It's more than that.
I can't keep track of them,
and it's exactly the same thing,
like three court,
a quarter of them say,
well,
you've given me the words to say what I
already knew was true,
and thank you for that.
I can see that in the audience.
It's so interesting because I can lay
out a story.
People go like this and say they're
doing that all the time.
It's like the lights are going on and
that's a really wild.
There's almost nothing better than that
to watch lights go on when you're
talking to people.
It's like,
that's just absolutely fantastic.
But to get this response from people.
My father,
I have,
my father's about 80,
80 is 83,
I think 81.
He's 81.
And uh,
I put him in charge of going through my
viewer email,
which is an overwhelming job.
But now we've had discussions about this
constantly.
He's overwhelmed by the fact that so
many people are writing and saying the
same thing.
It's like,
well,
I have a purpose,
man.
My life actually matters.
I finally realized that and I'm putting
it into practice and I'm bearing up
under the heaviest load I can imagine
and it's really helping.
It's like God and that's tens of
thousands of responses now,
so it's.
It's you couldn't hope for anything
better than that.
There's zero harm in it,
right?
It's just people putting their lives
together,
they're not mucking about with other
people and are trying to make broad
scale.
Social transformation is about which
they have no idea.
They're trying to make their immediate
environment better and it's working.
It's like great.
Great.
You say the zero harm in,
I'd say as a former legislator,
that there's an enormous amount of good
in a country is only the sum total of
the people that make it up to the extent
that they put together resilient
contribute,
don't have to ask others to help them.
The stronger the nation,
the society and rapidly like.
I mean,
I think I was thinking the other day,
some a journalist asked me why the
audience by people are responding so
positively to what I'm saying.
The young men for example,
and I thought,
hmm,
why?
Why?
Yeah.
That's a good question.
Says,
well,
I'm actually on their side.
I'm pretty happy that I'm really happy
that they're not wasting their lives.
I'm really sad to see that people are
disenchanted and nihilistic and
depressed and anxious and aimless and,
and perverse and vengeful and,
and all of those things.
It's terrible.
And then to see people question whether
that's necessary and then to start to
rise out of that.
It's like,
it's so fun.
Like last night I was at after my talk,
so overwhelming.
I don't usually think about these
things,
but I was,
I was after my talk last night and so
all these people line up and you know,
they have their 15,
15 seconds with me and they're kind of
tentative.
They're excited and attentive when they
come up to talk to me and then they
have,
you know,
15 seconds of time to tell me something.
I'm really listening to them and they're
hesitant about whether or not to share
the good news about their life.
You know?
And I think it's often because when
share good news about their life,
people don't necessarily respond
positively.
You know,
they don't give encouragement and people
need so little encouragement.
It's just unbelievable.
And so they're telling me something good
and I think,
God,
it's so good.
You know,
somebody says,
oh,
I'm getting along better with my father.
I haven't seen him for 10 years and now
we get along great.
And that,
the power of that,
you can't overstate the power of that
for individuals to get their life
together.
They individuals and unbelievably
powerful force and every single person
who gets their act together a little bit
has the capacity to spread that around
them.
It's,
it's a chain reaction and so it's a
lovely thing to see and that's
fantastic.